welcome good afternoon and welcome back
to remedy in turn hope you have a great
week first off let's say big a special
thank you to the NHS incredible work
it's been a tough week there have been
several restrictions lifted so we can
relax little but just stay smart stay
alert and be very clear bright steak and
potatoes in 10 minutes and tills we have
done a few of these in ten minutes right
yeah you've done one in ten minutes
thanks for the confidence kit that's not
very nice
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's have a look and Depp he's camping
hello excuse us go is that it kid
anything else no no no awesome oh well
right I said I said dinner in ten and I
promise that means steak and potatoes
but this is
and amazes thing tenders in Terminix oh
this is an amazing steak potatoes come
on chill get it going right let's go
wakey-wakey right first off get your gas
on I can't really put them pan down up
and down pan down make your tea okay
come down to me no no no to the pass on
okay there you go this is a grill okay
I'm gonna cook the steak on there
non-stick pan will do that with the
social potatoes so I've got leftover
potatoes I'll show that in a minute
get the gas all nice and high we're
gonna take this steak too rare okay and
then we'll let it rest it goes the
medium rare and then gonna put the most
amazing chimichurri right tell us
wakey-wakey - excuse me pan all over the
pan down ingredients start off -
maturing we're going with some crushed
garlic so beautiful experience for
experience and then from there red wine
vinegar extra virgin olive oil and some
honey a lot of people are too mature we
put sugar I don't see sugar in that the
honey gives it really nice rich velvety
texture herbs I've got some fresh mint
yeah next that's some peaceful parsley
pan down please don't pick it up and
then next to that I've got some
beautiful fresh basil lime and lemon the
zest and the juice and that's gonna be
secret the chimichurri but here's the
difference we're going to put the -
chewy on the steak so the chimichurri
absorbs inside at stake and it rests at
the same time it comes off a rare well
let's say off it literally means turn
the gas off forever
leave the steak on there first thing
pans night or not steak I've taken out
touch that tools it's room temperature
so that's not the fridge don't cook
steak straight from the fridge okay look
it all on there and then a little touch
of seasoning
both sides if you get it marinated now
room temperature okay it would literally
cook in no time so if the sirloin New
York Strip is a little bit too thick
take the rolling pin and sort of wrong
gently over and keep them literally okay
nice and thin now get your tongs once
that is
and crank up the heat okay come on there
again just the touch of oil pan down pan
now please get that oil nice and hot
right watch from that later state away
from you till you lay the steak earth oh
wait
there you go therefore doesn't splash on
we go now from there take your mushrooms
and your Tomatoes okay
and literally get the tomatoes on there
nice
get your mushrooms okay state tomatoes
and mushrooms okay like these these of
them okay now here's the most important
thing we want to take advantage of that
amazing grill it's all nice and hot and
you cook you like that sweet things
worked at once
crank up Peaks take your potatoes and
slice these people take their leftovers
they came nice and thin I want crispy
squid paper taters you can do wedges my
house I prefer these little disks and
I'll show you why
down please two minutes gone now you
sure did you start well actually started
cooking okay from there potatoes in okay
and literally keep them nice and flat
now what is here's we get some really
nice color on there I'm gonna going to
turn the steak once really important to
turn that steak once okay it's fine like
a crisp over there from there and it was
seasoning salt and pepper now we put
some onion and garlic in there but not
yes I know these so you may want to turn
that thing down but does okay get
underneath and just check those out I
saw once okay
[Music]
now okay the garlic in another and again
okay okay but from there take you I know
this is optional okay the flavor of the
onions on the garlic in with our
detectives delicious okay now step it
off for two minutes and from there slice
those ends up and go in over the
potatoes rolling out something useful
okay the butter helps to caramelize and
that beautiful flavor finishing so the
potato cutter is a big must hold a
little bit parsley back time to flip the
steak check this out turn down please
look at that beautiful that is the most
amazing sear
now look at that so cool and from there
I'm gonna put a little touch of butter
onto the grill now pretend to the garlic
working steak tomatoes and mushrooms all
starting to happen now
chimichurri crushed garlic in there
take your mint take your puzzle and take
your parsley and roll it up nice and
tiny okay
scrunch it up pen nicer clothes please
and don't over chop this okay just chop
it once if we go through that again it's
gonna bleed I want all that flavor
inside that garlic there you sit now
from there chilli
no come on sauce literally come on nice
and fine seeds in look this is amazing
the longer you marinate on top of that
steak the better and we want the steak
to be a really nice sort of medium-rare
from there
Chili's in now watch - nice tablespoons
of extra-virgin olive oil in okay a
tablespoon of red wine vinegar pan down
pan down in from there a nice tablespoon
of beautiful running honey ready honey
okay a nice touch of seasoning and then
we gonna make it today now watch my dad
please
and then I'm grinding that up there now
and that is a beautiful flavor okay
the chili the garlic the herbs are
bleeding in terms of flavor and looking
beautiful
now come this is where start to go up a
notch
check the stakeout
look at that there now from that turn
the gas off turn it off
shut up please that's a rare pretty go
to me to never turn off the gas now take
your three onions okay
and take the ends which are the sort of
the bitter and the chef's go away now
once we get to the right places
okay I want the tops of the greens
thrown into the pretenders okay I don't
want these really nice bright pieces
like this into the chimichurri okay and
then finally okay my down madam madam
madam madam madam bow down make happy
birthday darling
twenty-two years of age oh my goodness
me there oh you're legally you can do
anything you want
well twenty-one or twenty-two hand down
now look it needs a touch more olive oil
okay lemon zest in there okay and she
goes no fresh lemon juice over the
chimichurri pen and please can you pan
in there and this is where it goes off
the level watch okay now that is so
delicious come over please sit that on
top of the steak okay yeah that is going
to continue cooking is going from rare
to medium-rare but the marinade is going
to be absolutely incredible
okay I like to set that honey the flavor
is out of this world
now take the recipe parsley and just
very quickly shop how longer this please
beautiful flat leaf parsley with time I
put my rosemary rose we go see with the
state to flavor it and then forget a
minute ago right now for the exciting
part pan down please pin down come down
no no first off build this beautiful
mushrooms okay
and that I take my tomatoes whether
those two martyrs seriously that are you
kidding me they are not burnt
stop that they are not the potatoes on
stage place that on there and then just
take you all to chewy
I just drizzle that like believe first
time except weeks
the most amazing state of Texas with a
delicious fragrant chimichurri all the
names of Megan James is programmed with
22nd birthday oh that's not a little bit
we miss you and we love you
[Music]